moi j'avais une blague sur les
perroquets c'est bien raisonnable moi
j'ai une blague sur les perroquets de
jean michel maes qu elle est grossière
oui non seulement qu'elle doit l'être
énormément allons danser c'est la femme
qui défendra son mari je suis désolé et
chérie j'ai fait une bêtise j'ai acheté
un perroquet aujourd'hui
et les bailleurs le problème n'est pas
ce que je vais acheter au bordel du coin
qui vient de fermer ça me faisait de la
peine ils sont foutus au la fourrière au
syndrome je viens de là raconte âge tel
que j'achète perroquets et ils
n'arrêtent pas de nous insulter ta fille
et moi il ne traite de [ __ ] depuis deux
heures
depuis le marivaux ou pas le construire
jmahri l'image perd et ça quand je
rentre du boulot il s'est fait rare il
rentre du boulot il arrive à peine de
saluer en taille jal perroquet quand on
hurlait à sa femme il finit par entrer
au salon et le perroquet d'ivoire
on a changé les buts mais c'est toujours
les mêmes pillon
[Applaudissements]